so many of you may be familiar with this
story it was the top of viral trend on
the fifth
what does Elon Musk and Grimes's baby
name actually mean and the big the
reason why this is interesting
I don't care he named his kid something
like x AE or whatever it's called
but they're seconds illegal yeah that
that I have an issue with I don't know
if I believe it's illegal it is it is a
stupid name and I think is it legal yeah
they name their kid what they name their
kid whatever don't tell me what here
don't tell me what I can name my kid
here's the name no it's X I a 12 Musk
the a and the e symbol I was reading
about it is apparently been pronounced
as I or a or E whatever the I've mostly
heard a pronounced as E right I don't I
don't know have you seen it so so like
Exia 12 Exia 12 I mean XE has a cool
name that's cool XE yeah that's a cool
name but apparently they're saying they
think it's like excess excess Shea or
something okay okay so apparently
they're saying it might be illegal who's
who's telling them it's illegal
well get out of here with that I don't
want to read this through particular
intro they did because they like the
problem with websites like slate is they
try to it's like having a kid tell you a
story where they try to add things to
make it sound fun when it's really just
wasting your time yeah yeah I totally
know we talked about yeah the flame
throwing hot flamethrower Hawking
billionaire tycoon as I just shut up we
know Elon Musk has please calm down yeah
what did he do come on well it a baby
boy was born Monday night and if Musk's
hazy tweets are to be believed please he
has been christened X II a 12 musk
rather than using a press release a
Notes app statement or just keeping the
news private musk has chosen to mete out
updates on the newborn in the somewhat
khattak way he often does by replying to
select tweets his fans have directed his
way it's like he is so committed to
being a reply guy oh just shut up mom
and baby are good Musk tweeted when
Priscilla banana asked for the name
that's when he wrote X EA 12 musk to
Tesla Gong he offered a picture of the
baby but edited so it looked like he had
a kid face tattoos o to be a billion
with no impulse control in the Twitter
account see this is what I'm talking
about right here
see shut up Oh to be a billionaire I
don't care
stop adding this stupid trash I mean is
this actually the name or is he just
trolling peeps at least rolling I mean
come on he's clear his seems like he's
trolling and if he isn't who cares
that's the name he chose okay what if
what if the name is actually spelled e K
SPE hey you why sure exia okay XE a and
then 12 whatever even if it is 12
whatever and then and then he just wrote
it that way
I think it's so apparently they're there
what is this let me read it let me
realize street it they're saying some
people are arguing it's supposed to be X
ash Ark Archangel who made that up
that's like made-up what is this again
based on ambiguous Twitter behavior on
the part of musk he linked to a post
posting this it may look more like a
math equation than a name but the
character is apparently said as ash well
I looked up on Wikipedia I've never
heard it pronounced that way and they
say it's most typically pronounced as e
or or you know EEO or something and a 12
has been used as a codename for our type
of plane uh-huh but the baby name expert
had consulted Laura wattenberg movie
name expert yeah oh yeah baby name
expert author of the book author of a
book and founder of multiple websites
about baby names has her doubts that XE
a twelve could really be the child's
name many states have laws on the books
about the names people can be given says
what you can't tell me what I can name
like yeah and like it wait excuse me
they say this name isn't likely to pass
legal muster the couple presumably
presumably lives in California and
California like many states defines
names as consisting of letters
specifically the 26 letters of the
English alphabet in fact there has been
a battle in California or over even
making diacritics like accents until
these illegal part of the name what if
your name is written in like I don't
know Chinese or Swedish I mean there's
plenty of different yeah it's like okay
I've yeah they just went straight if we
give my our child a Swedish name it's
like I would laugh in the face of anyone
who said what I can't
can't be true though because I've seen
people who have like dots over the you
and like exact and an accent I've seen
that yeah but is it on their license and
is it in California because I guess I
guess it's saying here and you're not
allowed to and get out of here
California's got a large Asian
population but they you know they do
they just romanticize like okay they
just change it yeah yeah it sounded
spelled in English stupid yeah here's
what she says if they don't like accent
marks chances are they'll have a problem
with e it's it's an a in and E together
I don't know how to describe it this
used to be using in Magic the Gathering
actually like aether ether ether right
ether ether however you pronounce it and
then they actually recently just got rid
of it like two years ago and changed it
to just the a in the EU because it's not
on the keyboard so yeah actually like is
it where does it fall in line and
alphabet yeah here we go they say mom by
way of example wattenberg pointed to the
story of a man whose birth name was
Michael Dengler who spent years in court
in the 70s trying to change his legal
name to the number 10 69 and did not
succeed it she added the government data
that government databases as well as we
recently seen those can be so difficult
to update that's effectively impossible
will strip out punctuation and internal
capitalization substitute AE substitute
a and E for the AE symbol and reject
numeric characters so exci a12 would
become Exia Exia zaiah as a as a cool
name too
oh yeah maybe that's what it is always
he just wrote all the different ways we
pronounce that it's pretty cool I'm
liking his name Haim are now putting
matters of taste aside X Y 12 is a
wildly impractical name wattenberg went
on it's not only hard to spell and
remember and virtually unpronounceable
it's not even easily typable and no
forms or databases will accept it it's
simply non-functional my gosh it up and
it's a bigger than this person this is
their real name choice it's a it's in a
whole different class other than
celebrity baby names then people object
to on a date on the basis of style it
fails at the basic job of being a
contemporary American name I don't care
you can't tell me what what word like
you know what
hold on man they're telling us ZZZ our
zoos am floor bow bounce David you can't
call your kid XC at 12 right really
sorry man I'm know you can't put a
number in a kid's name says who says who
it's a social construct yeah so what I
can't I can call my kid what I want to
call my kid
I'm gonna call my kid let's see gene
gene okay yeah
that's simple that's the joke you get
the gene pool gene pool fails here's a
quote fails at the basic job of being a
contemporary American name would sound
to a lot of us like failure I doubt it
would do I doubt it would to musk and
Grimes perhaps the only answer for them
was going to be a name that fails at
being a name and therefore deconstructs
the concept of people having names in
general in that case mission
accomplished
though of course there's something else
there's there someone else who did it
first were they talking about Prince Oh
who's this unpronounceable love symbol
yep Prince he's the artist formerly
known as Prince you know I gotta admit
there's something to this challenging
social norms and social constructs okay
so I get well my assumption of what he's
trying to do is like she like this this
woman mentioned challenging the notion
of what a name should or could be right
because how would he tell someone you
can't name your kid yeah whatever you
want
exactly it's like how can anyone say
well what I'm gonna name my kid so hexia
yeah it's a cool name
so I see a 112 sure but think about all
of these other social constructs so I
understand the sentiment behind like the
pronouns thing okay I think they're
wrong because it's ridiculous but I mean
call yourself whatever you want I don't
care
the they/them thing doesn't work like I
was talking to a friend about this and I
wrote something there saying oh they is
the right way to say you know for people
non-binary and so then I just replied
with something that was unintelligible
using they pronouns and they're like
what does that mean I'm like I use today
what do you mean what's broad yeah yeah
but there is something to like
challenging social constructs and one of
the best examples being journalism and
calling out awful journalism like this
is how like award systems work okay you
know awards work for news no not really
work for one of these establishment news
organizations okay you
AFE and you ask them for the award and
they say okay seriously that's just how
it works you're not even like rewarded
by I mean technically you're weird but
if I was like you know Adam hey you want
to give me an award for doing that
switch blonde in the mini ramp I would
thank you sir I'm an award-winning
skateboarder by the way nice only if you
give me an award - it's off your
winnings Adam Adam did would you do have
half-cab Blount half-cab Blount to rock
fakie yeah no yeah I hereby I hereby
award you Tim pools skateboarding award
for excellence that's it I quit I'm out
Adam is gonna go Adam is now in a war
Malone's game done I quit so this is my
prime so so you know in the context of
challenging social constructs I can
respect I can get it like who says
you're an expert you're educated you
know like I always had a joke where I
would tell people if they asked me I'm
Isaac will drop out by the way and they
would say things like did you go to
college whatever bike oh oh yes
absolutely I have a PhD in the back
really and what not be like political
science and nuclear physics actually let
both of them like oh yeah yeah yeah I
did both the same time actually and
they'll go Wow and they never ask you
what's cool and they never follow up on
anything they don't ask you any
questions and that just it so you can
just say it but whenever whenever rarely
someone would be alike you don't really
have that what school did you go to I
would say it's the University of Milton
what's that I made it up it's not an
accredited credited school yeah but you
never asked so this is like you know I
printed out my own little certificate
saying that I I can't agree
yeah phony diploma calm seriously yep so
the reason I bring this up is a lot of
people think inside the box so I got a
respectable Muskies doing here I get it
I'm down don't want anybody tell you
can't name your kids XE at 12 yeah do
you think man agree I mean I got it i
got admit if you're a kid you grew up
with that name you probably upset
nah people probably call you X no way
you'd be cool with that I I don't know
it depends on who raises the kid to
handle different things you know like
you imagine he's gonna have he's gonna
have Elan musk as his dad I mean he's
gonna it'sit's his dad and Grimes as his
mom it's like they're I mean they're
power couple like
I mean what are they what is he that
bright gonna have anything to worry
about nothing to try and log into his
email I'm gonna be like please enter
your name he's gonna put X space AE
symbol put X period done next and then
it's gonna say too few characters figure
something out
Elon Musk will have a full-on keyboard
design tool or they'll just write I
don't have all right e x ee y a XE cilia
this whole thing you know what this is
interesting it's like people have been
seeing through this pandemic they're
like wow celebrity is whatever we don't
care about celebrities anymore they're
just regular people and now now the
celebrities are scientists or not
scientists but like people that are you
know I'm little Grimes as a musician
right are artists but you on you know
he's making moves he's you know space
moves and it's cool I I'm happy that
this is at least who they're gossiping
I think musk is a cool dude I do too
yeah yeah everybody it's all mad but he
did do that tweet about Tesla stock
price being too high yeah when and then
people were like dude you literally just
took money from me like why would you do
that that was kind of that's kind of a
bummer move to do you saw when he
between that right yeah there was one
guy who tweeted I just lost ten thousand
dollars because of because of this tweet
what's what are you doing man yeah we
did it mus last Friday we talked about
it I don't think he was his list of
tweets yeah I don't think he was
considering what it was gonna happen by
doing that he's gonna hurt people yeah I
think he's a cool dude I don't think
he's meeting I mean and and now he just
had his baby
sounded like he was pretty stressed out
with a pregnant girl like I don't know
if they're just girlfriend
they're just yeah boyfriend girlfriend
or whatever but whatever I was like he's
about to have a kid he does he's got
like four different businesses he runs
yep dude is stressed whatever yeah
everybody's yelling at him they're
claiming that the only reason he wants
the government to reopen the economy's
is because losing money because he wants
get a payout right and I think that's
why he tweeted the price was too high to
be like okay if that's what you think
boom prices too high he did get it he
did ding ding ding what's gonna do it
all that money Bobby I've been stationed
spaceship dude I feel bad for the kids
of rich people though it's not I don't I
don't I feel bad because I agree
you you you don't learn about survival
not the same way yeah I know a lot of
people who were who were born into
wealthy families man they would not
survive in the event of a Boogaloo yeah
they're gonna be alive they're not
they're not bad people they're not
stupid people they just don't have that
skill set they don't they don't
understand the concept of like doing
things yourself being in the cold true
that - yeah it's it's like yeah they
were coats and stuff but it's like if
you ask somebody in Chicago like what do
you do in a storm the average person can
be like you know here's some things you
gotta do to take care of yourself but
you know there's an interesting question
that someone someone asked me once do
you think Donald Trump has ever walked
more than like one city block the answer
is obviously yes yeah yeah but the
question is interesting because if the
real question is what's the most you
think Donald Trump has ever walked hmm
like maybe rarely in his life he's
walked a long distance for sure I'm sure
he's walked through New York and walked
a whole lot but the reason the question
was asked is because he's a person who
his whole life always had a limo waiting
for him so where for like me growing up
I had to skate three miles to get to the
park hang off my friends yeah so that
was like an hour of you know of
traveling you know combination of
walking skating yeah and then you
finally get there
granted it's pretty slow walking and
skating but you finally get there you do
that every single day and back it's a
it's a little journey you gotta take ya
use every day to work in New York right
but if you're rich you walk out of your
house the guy opens the door for you get
your limo you say skate park yeah yeah
so I don't know though whatever man Elon
Musk can do it he wants he named his kid
whatever he wants I feel bad because
they're gonna be very very separated for
the rest of society with a very strange
name with a very wealthy family honestly
I don't think the name had anything to
do with that fact he's gonna be
separated from society anyway yeah
what's his name to have anything to do
with it doesn't yeah
so whatever name Musk boom it's a cool
name I think it's a cool name man I
couldn't imagine growing up in the
shadow of somebody else like the
pressure to be good or better or to live
up to what they were you know Elon Musk
is living up to his own so he's not and
okay
seems Grimes I know you're talking about
his kid but it's like he is fulfilling
what he wants to do and Grimes it feels
the same so it's not like they're gonna
dish that on their kid that kid is gonna
probably do whatever they want to do
it's not about that about the rest gonna
be a smart kid to the rest of society
being like you know oh your must kid so
you have to do these things and then
they're gonna feel pressure I don't
think so
like I don't think Elon or Grimes feels
that way and they're gonna project that
onto their kid in in the in a good way
maybe I think their kids gonna be one
cool cat yeah yeah maybe just because
I'm ambitious you know like if it were
me and like my dad was was Musk yeah I
would be like I will be better yeah
that's a whole I mean actually iteration
now look at look at look at Rome
his dad was like a famous like Russia's
a famous like a wealthy real estate guy
yeah Trump was like I'm gonna do better
and he did yeah the president I mean he
knows better he got his name on top of
buildings all around the world sure well
it's his dad's like well was his dad
Trump or Trump Trump Trump okay I think
this is grandfather was his grandfather
yeah yeah
so he's doing his whole family he's
stamping his name all over the place
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you